今日は式のことを終わりまして
心の説明に入ります 全部まとめて説明するのは色々難しいですから
いくらか大雑把な説明だけにしようと思いますけど
式の方はまだいろいろ話は残ってますけどね
でもあまり難しくて複雑で
一般的にはちょっと理解しにくいところがありますので
そこら辺は で まあそういうことで
今度は心というところ
アビダンマでは生起体という
この本当の心理っていうのは何ですけれど
心と物質とと精神です
それから心想ですね 最後に涅槃という解脱ということを四つしか見てないんですね
ですから 普通の世界の人々はいろんなものをあるあると言うんだけど
仏教ではそういうものはあるのではなくて
この基本的な四つしか存在しないんだと
それも心一つで 心に現れる心所がもう一つで
物質的なエネルギーは一つで
最後に出世間的な涅槃というもので
そういうものも決して永遠なものではなくて
心も心所も物質的なものも全部生滅変化している無常なものなんですね
それから幻想であって
その時々一時的に現れるものであると
全ての現象を乗り越えたところで涅槃という状態が現れるのであって
それはそれに付いては永遠ということも
あるいは何も言葉には関係ないと
わかりやすくは不死なり境地とかは言いますけどね
そういうふうな四つでありまして
今日はその中で心という説明
で 大体あちこち僕は心の話をすると
この心はなかなか理解してくれないし
理解していらっしゃる方々もいますけど
いつでも今まで自分たちが持っているこの魂の概念から抜けられなくて
それには何か他の言葉でも偉そうに入れ替えるだけなんですね
菩薩 八祖菩提心とかなんとかどうか
如来蔵とかね いろんな言葉を入れ替えられ
法身とか法蔵とかね 蔵というんですか
日本語であるかどうかわかりませんだけど
sanskrit でそういうことはありますけど
この蔵っていうのはお蔵っていう法っていうのは心理ですね
そういういろいろ言葉を置き換えたりして
日本になってくると大日如来とかね
久遠仏陀とかね そういう言葉まで作っちゃって
結局我ですか 実体ですか
魂ですか 永遠にもう変化しない絶対的な何かあるんだっていう風によく考えているんですね
だからみんなこの基本的な論理わかってないんです
何か永遠で全く変化しないというものは
もうどういうものかと
ということは何も影響を受けないということなんですね
触っても蹴っても焼いても茹でても何も変化しないんだから永遠なんです
焼いたら焼けるものは永遠じゃないんだから
ですから もし永遠的な絶対的な魂
霊魂のような神様のようなものがいるならば
それはそのままで我々には何の関係もないんですね
どうすることもできない
喋っても我々の話は聞いてくれない
なぜならば 聞くということは変化だから
反応することだから 反応しちゃったら変化するんでしょうに
だから もし永遠な絶対的な何か神様がいるならば
こちらでいくら祈りしたっても聞こえないんです
全く永遠な絶対的なものだから
だからこちらは一生懸命修行して死んじゃって
神様のところに生まれ変わろう
梵我一如になろうと思っても
なりっこはないんです
向こうは受け取りませんだから
もし新しい新しい魂が向こうの絶対的な魂にスイッチすると
その魂は増えちゃうでしょうに
物質的に考えれば増えるというんだけど
物質でなくても もう何とかの形に違う魂がつけるんだから
例えばこのヒンドゥー教だったら
この水に例えられて 例えば海があって
海にはいっぱい水があるんですね
それで川から水が入っちゃったら
もう海の水であって何のこともないんではないか
そういう風に個が個人の我が修行して悟って真我に入ったら一緒の同じ真我になりますよと
説明はわかりやすいんだけど
ただそれだけのことです
でも海は絶対的な永遠なもので
何も変化しないものだったら
どうやって川の水を受け入れますかね
入らないんです 入ったって水と油のように別々なっちゃいます
追っ払いますから このもう変化するものは嫌だと
もしかすると ですから
そういう概念というのは
基本的な理屈も論理も
わかってないんです 神様は怒ってるみたい
この野郎と  [笑い]ですから
そういう概念で物事を考えたって
仏教ではそういう概念はないということに
ですから 心というものを理解するときも
何か心というものがあるんだと思ったら
ある面では困るんですね
何か特別に実体としてあるというわけじゃなくて
そういう実体として何もない
この体も実体としてあるものじゃないんですね
いずれにせよ 私は言うのだ
川というものがあるといえばあるんだけど
でも川はあるところ 例えば 10メートルぐらいの川を見ていると
それは瞬間瞬間変化して新しい川になっちゃうんですね
ただ 我々は言葉上 川という普通の常識で
でも中の水という水が川なんですね
水がなければ川じゃないんだから
だから川というためには水が必要なんですね
でもその水はもうずっと流れて新しい新しい水になっているんですね
だから同じ水一滴がまた戻ってくるかというと
そういうこともないんですね
新しい水が入ってきて
そこの 10メートルぐらい
我々見ているところの川が出来上がって
またその一瞬も止まることなく
その水がまた出ていっちゃうし
また新しい水が入っちゃうし
そこに我々は 100年経っても川
川 川 川だというんであって
それで言葉に引っかかって
この川はもうずっと昔からありましたよとかという風に言っちゃうんですね
だからこの体もそういう風に川のように流れて流れていくんですね
言ってもなかなかそれを理解しようとしないだけ
ちょっと考えれば この我々はすーっと空気吸ってるでしょうに
どれぐらい量の空気を吸ってるんですかね
ですから この外にある空気を体に入れちゃうでしょ
その分 体の物質を外に出してるんですね
だから川のようにもう体も流れてるんです
そういうこと考えたって
我々は何トンぐらいの食べ物を食べたんですかね
そういう食べたものをここに入れると
そのぐらいの分は体から外へ出してるんですね
いろんな形で ですから
ずっと全部この体さえ流れて流れて流れてるんで
髪の毛にしてもずっと伸びっぱなしでしょうに
そこで切って切って切って
これ私の髪ですよと言うんだけど
結局毎日新しい髪が生まれてくるんです
それはもう外から受け入れる物質から作られているものですから
そこに自分という実体
体あると言ったっても
どこら辺にその実体変化しない物質がありますかというと
そんなことはないんですね
心はもっとより早く変化していくんですね
だから そこに問題は私という実感があることなんですね
これは私の体 これは私の考え方というふうに
これは私ですよと思うところで問題があるんですよ
なぜならば 私というものは全然つかめないもので
実体がないもので 逃げるもので
私は悲しいですよという人は
ほんのちょっとのことでまた楽しくなったりするし
原因変わっちゃったらもう楽しいんですね
ものすごくもう舞い上がって喜んでいる人は
ちょっとその条件変わっちゃったら
またすごく悲しくなってしまっちゃうし
元気だ元気だという人は
ちょっと足でも滑っちゃったら骨が折れても三ヶ月だ
もうそれで病気になってしまっちゃうし
ですから すぐ変わってしまっちゃうんですね
ですから 心というものもそういうふうなものだと理解してほしいんです
ただ いろんな形のエネルギーの流れであって
何も実体はございませんと
それから心は何ですかと理解するために
私はもう 最近よく言ってる最近というのは
僕はいつ私の説明のやり方を変えるかと自分でわからない
すぐ変えちゃうんです
説明の仕方っていうのは
ですから 今あの 大体二
三回しか同じ解釈をしませんだけど
でもちょっと使い過ぎなんです
いつも私が言うのは この体っていうのは物体として見なさいと
一つのはもう何にも変化も変化ではなくて
動き何もできない 椅子机のような物体として見なさいと
そうすると我々はただ椅子と自分が同じですかと言えば
同じわけじゃないんですね
建物と自分が同じかというと
じゃあ私もこの建物 全く同じものだと見たところで
何が違うんですかと この建物と私の場合は
建物は物質であって 物体であって
私も物体であって でも私は何かが違う
その何かが違うのは何ですかと具体的に聞いてみましょうと
そうすると見つかるの見つかるところは全部心という大きなカテゴリの中に入れてみましょう
例えば 私は見る 聞く 建物は見る
聞くことはしない じゃあ見る聞くことは心ですと
私は寒い熱いと感じる
それも心ですと 歩いたり動いたりする
それも心ですよと 私の体がどんどん変化して変わっていく
それは建物の変化とは違うんですね
変化は 建物はどんどん老化していく
この体もどんどん老化していくんだけど
また再生するという働きも入ってるんですね
ですから 建物の老化と体の老化っていうのは
もうなんとなく形が違うんですね
再生しながら老化する
建物はただ老化するだけ
そこでこの その働き もういわゆる生きているということですね
それも心の働きだと 入れておこうと
それから悲しみ 苦しみ
楽しみなどなど感じる
それもじゃあ心の働き
それは建物と違って私だけは考えている
あ 考えていることも心の働きだ
寝たりする あ 寝ることも心の働きだ
それ自分勝手にいろんなものを物質を取ったりする
取ってこの物体に入れたりする
それは建物はそれはしないんです
ですから それもいわゆる食べ物を食べること
それも心の働きだと 食べ物というのは物質であって
それを取って判断して入れるということは
心の働きであって そういう風に見ると心はわかりませんと
不思議なものだというのはおかしいんですね
いつでも私たちはやっている行動は心の行動であって
私たちは物体と物体と差がつけてくれるもの
働きは心の働きであります
でも 心というの場合も
よく言っている次の例えは
この どの例えでもいいんですけど
野菜でもいいんですけど
野菜という言葉があります
野菜はありますか？と言ったら
誰でも答えるのは野菜はあります
果物はあります 果物はちゃんと実際にありますと
そうすると野菜は何ですか？と言うといっぱい色んなこと言わなくちゃいけない
キャベツはあるし ジャガイモあるし
まあいろいろあるんですね
それでじゃあ野菜の中で野菜たるもの
いわゆる本来の本当の野菜は何ですか？って言ったらどっちですかね？じゃが美ですか？ほうれん草ですか？セロリですか？どっちですかね
どっちでもなくなっちゃうんですね
その場合は野菜という働きの一部になってしまっちゃうんですね
だからキャベツはキャベツであって野菜ですと
ほうれん草はほうれん草であって
また野菜ですと そうすると野菜というものは本当は見つからなくなっちゃうんですね
いろんなものにまとめて野菜という
我々のいろんな働きをまとめて心という
人間がその心を心を探しているんですね
霊魂がどこにありますか？魂はどこにありますか？この霊魂魂っていうのは実感というものなんですね
自分という感覚に 私たちは私と言うんですね
それをお釈迦様はどこに生まれますかと
自分で考えるところで
ものを見て私が見ていると言っちゃう実感が生まれる
聞いて私が聞いていると思っちゃう
そこでもう聞いたり見たりする主なる主体なる私がいるんじゃないかと人々は考えている
でも 聞くこと見ることは全く違うものではないかと
そういうことで無我論
実体はないんだと 存在として
で 仏教の話が出来上がってるんですね
すごく合理的に具体的に考えてできているものです
だから 何の証拠もないもの
何の証拠もないものは我なんですね
魂なんですね アートマンというものなんですね
それあるというためには
何の証拠もないんです
どのように頑張っても
どんな高度な修行して
どんな高度なサマーディ得ても
ない これ私だと そこで瞑想して
それで真我を探そうという努力はあったんです
そこまで頑張って探す必要ありますかと
そんなに魂という実体あるならば
堂々とあるはずでしょうに
それは難しい苦行して
もう何十年も時間かけて修行したところで
ウパニシャッドなんかの時代の仙人たちがやっと真我見つかりましたと
それぐらい隠れているものですかと
本物は とも聞きたくなるんですけど
で その場合もお釈迦様は
じゃあそれも経験してみようと
その普通の瞑想の世界にあるサマーディの境地は
まあ最終最後のところまで経験してみるんですね
それ以上は進めないというところありますから
どんなものにも で そこまで成長したっても
確かに喜悦感 喜悦感がある
確かに幸福感が感じる
それは世の中で誰にでも考えられない
もう感じることできないほどの無量の幸福感が感じる
それは正しいんですが
それは真我ではありませんと
ただ ありとあらゆるものから心は離れると
すごく余裕を感じることだけですと
というふうなことで 魂だけはもういくら探し求めても見つからないものであって
だから見つからないんだからあるというならば
それはちょっとした常識の論理にはなり得ないものなんですね
見つからないんだからありますよと
では そうすると見つかっているものはないと
となっちゃうんですね
だから堂々と宗教はそういう論理を持ってるんです
例えば我々はきちんと体験している世界にはマーヤーというんですね
マーヤーっていうのはイリュージョン
イリュージョン 幻覚 幻
それは仏教でこの言葉たまに使うんですけど
まあ言葉だから まあヒンドゥー教だったら大変大事な言葉で
ですから 私たちは実際に体験している世界はマーヤー
イリュージョンであって
全然体験していないものはもう本物であるという論理は堂々と使っているんです
誰も気が付かないんですね
こちらに この論理的にちょっとおかしいんじゃないかと
絶対体験できないものは事実
本当のことであって 体験するものは嘘ですよと
掴めるものは嘘ですよと
いわゆる証拠あるならばそれは嘘であって
証拠ないならばそれは本物であるという
そんな論理なんですね
それはもっと即的に当てはめてみると
バカバカらしいということはよく見つかる
例えば人は包丁でも鉄砲でも持って人を刺したり撃ったりしているのは自分が見ている
見たところで人を殺される
そうすると犯人はもう堂々と分かってるでしょ
そこで犯人は凶器ですか
それも持っている その人の指紋もある
それでその人をもっと探してみたら
その人に対するすごい恨みもずっとあったし
殺すわけもありましたし
それで殺す計画も立てたことがあるんだと
それを首領やいろいろ見つかる
それで証拠っていうのはもう上にも揃っている
それだったら いっぱい証拠あるんだから
あなたは犯人ではありません
どこら辺の何か他の人を殺しまって
あなたにとってはその人を見たこともない
会ったこともない 考えたこともない
そんな人は住んでいるかないかもあなたは知らなかったと
だからあなたは犯人ですよと言えますかね
その論理だったら だから犯人にするためには
犯人は被害者が見たこともなく
聞いたこともなく そういう人がいるかないかもわからない
世の中で被害者が それだったらその人は犯人ですよとは言えないんですね
実際には だからその論理は
まあ魂の場合はもう宗教の世界でもう残念ながら使ってるんです
まあそういう話は一応置いておいて
その心っていうのは ですから実体として何かどこかで体の中に隠れているものっていう感じじゃなくて
このすごくこの まあ掴みにくいことは掴みにくいかもしれませんだけど
我々見たり聞いたり感じたり考えたり
寝たり起きたりするその働きをやらせている
そのそこら辺は心ですよと
ですから 例えば機械 物体だったら触っても物体は知りません
でも私たちの体を触ったら知る
ですから 皮膚の皮膚の上で心という働きが仕事をしている
そこで問題はこの現代の物理学的な科学なんですね
科学っていうのは純粋物理学なんですね
で 心理学は科学的に もうもう何て言いますか
作ることさえヨーロッパでは難しいんですね
もうもうほとんど最近なんですね
一応扱ったのは心理学
普通の学問として 今まではまあへんてこりんな考え方だと思っていたんですね
魂あるというならばそれはそれでいいんだと
でも心はああだこうだで
それはもうとんでもないんだと
学問じゃないんだと言ってきて
やっとまあ最近 現代時代では心の心理学の方を一つのちゃんとした学問として
科学的な学問として扱うようになってるんだけど
いまだに科学的じゃないんですね
それ で まあそれはそれで
この物質的な物質論から見ると
じゃあ皮膚を皮膚 触れたら何かに
皮膚が何かに触れたら感じると
それは神経の働きではないかと
神経があって 神経は触れたという情報を電気信号として
物質の化学変化として脳に連絡して
それで知ってるんだと
ですから それには簡単に物質的な説明ありますと
というんです で 考えること
記憶さえ 単なる なんて言いますか
化学変化だと 何か考えて考えて覚えてしまえば
それで脳の中で化学変化が起こるんだと
化学的な それが記憶であると
ですから もう何だかんでも物質的に説明しようとする
その辺の区別するために
私はこういう説明をまた出すんですね
じゃあ物体もあるし それから我々に見える機械があるんですね
世の中で ありとあらゆる機械
車とかロボットとか まあいろんな機械だらけだから
私たちの世界っていうのは
で 物体と機械と生命体と三つ考えてみましょうと
そう三つ考えてみると
その差がわかるんですね
この体も物体というよりは機械的物体なんですね
で 機械のやり方っていうのは
機械が自分に言った仕事
いわゆる組まれている仕事はする
それ以上何もできません
だから車だったら まあエンジンかけたら車輪が回ってどこか行くことは
移動することはできる
車輪がカチカチに変化することによって
左 右に曲がったりする
後ろに行くこともそれぐらいできると
とにかく移動する それにしか車には仕事をできない
じゃああなたに移動できるんだから
コンビニエンスストアで缶ジュースでも買ってこいと言ったら
それはできないんですね
なぜならばそういうプログラムないんだから
車に だから機械には決まってる仕事しかできないんです
この体も機械だと見るとよくわかるんです
一部一部にやっぱり決まってる仕事があるんですね
それは機械的なことで
ですから 体は機械的な物体なんですね
で 体はただの機械かといえば
またそうでもないでしょうに
どんなコンピューターにも
どんな機械にもできないものが体にできるんですね
一番わかりやすいのは考えることなんですね
もう一つは予想しないことをできるんですね
体には じゃあ缶ジュース買おうとコンビニエンスストアに行った人は
いきなり考え方を変えて
パチンコ屋さんに行ってパチンコやっているかもしれませんね
あるいはこういう缶ジュース買ってくださいと名前言ったところで
店に行ってみたところで
もっといいものが見つかって
じゃあそれじゃなくてそれにしようと
ということは どんな機械にもできないんですね
コンピューターも何も考えることはできない
決まってるように ように動くしかできないんですね
そこら辺のその働きはもう純粋たる心の働きなんですね
この生命 どんな生命の身も
微生物にも 微生物も機械なんですけど
機械的物体ですが そこにまた生命的な働きまたあるんですね
機械はやらないことはやらない
やれないことはできると
環境は まあ一番わかりやすいのは環境はに敏感というか
周りに敏感 それから自分の生命を維持しようとする
機械は絶対それだけはしない
私は長生きしたいんだと
このようにすれば 私はもう私
この機械はもう何にも持ちませんよということは全くしないんですね
でも 生命体の場合は機械なんですけど
より長生きしようと微生物も頑張ってるんですね
それから子孫を作ろうということは
それは機械はやらないことで
生命としての機械だけやってることです
そういういろんな働きがありますから
それは心の働きなんですね
風に理解しておけば 心は何とかわかるんじゃないかな
そこでこの 定義として言うと
果物を定義しなさい 野菜定義しなさいと言ったら定義できるんですね definition
野菜というのは まあこういうこういう植物であって
人間は食べるものである
それは野菜なんですね
植物は野菜ですよとは言わないんですね
植物でありながら人間食べ食べられるものは野菜である
まだ定義もう少々変わるんです
で 体に栄養とエネルギーを与えてくれるものは野菜であって
植物で食べられるのはまたあるんですね
薬とか 薬には野菜と言わないんですね
それは栄養のために食べるんじゃないんです
ですから ちゃんと我々のはあの薬と野菜の定義できる
じゃあ果物といえば何ですかと
ちゃんと定義できるんですね
例えば決して葉っぱは果物にならないんですね
野菜の場合は葉っぱも根も実も何でも野菜になるんです
トマトは野菜でしょうに
ホウレンソウも野菜でしょうに
それから白いあれ 何でしたっけ
大根とか野菜でしょうに
でも大根とホウレンソウとトマト
植物 その違う違う部分でしょ
それからあの菊とかありますね
食用の花 いろいろあります
食べられる花っていうのは
あのハイビスカスも食べられます
で またまあ日本では僕はあんまりそれしかわかりませんだけど
でもハイビスカスなかなか手に入りませんね
で あれはまあお茶通してもおいしく飲めますけど
で まだもう本当に野菜らしい花もあるんです
ああ コールフラワーっていうのなんでしたっけ
うん コールフラワーっていうのは花でしょ
カリフラワーっていうんですか
で まあそれはもう正真正銘の野菜で花なんですね
ですから 野菜といえば花と実も根とかいろいろあります
でも果物の場合は？果物として食べる芋とかありますか
え？ 何でますか あの なんとか芋ですか
もう砂糖入れて煮て食べますけど
この何芋ですか サツマイモとかね
それはもうわざわざおかずにするだけであって
果物ではないんですね
ですから 果物を定義するとちゃんとわかるんです
それは木の実はフルーツですから
あくまでもフルーツなんです
だから英語の言葉はきちんと
まあ果物と言ったって同じ言葉ですからね
フルーツなんです ですから
葉っぱは入りません 根は入りません
幹は入りません それでまた味も決まってるんですね
果物の場合は まあ大体大体はまあ甘くなければ果物にならないんですね
ですから まあ甘さがあって
その植物の実であってというふうな
もう定義できるんですね
だから定義できるんだから
元来の本物のもともとの果物があるといえば
それがないんです 果物たる標準的な
ちゃんとした正真正銘の果物があって
他のものは別々なものだということはないんです
たまにまあなんか怪しいものもありますけど
野菜であって果物でもあるというものもありますけど
これは日本ではあまり覚えられ思い出しませんだけど
まあ僕らの世界ではまあ野菜にするか果物にするかと
まあ一応考えて じゃあ今度は野菜にしよう
今度は果物にしようと
いい例とのジャックフルーツ
ジャックフルーツなんですね
ジャックフルーツ でっかいものってものすごく大きいんだけど
熟する前にはちゃんとした野菜なんですね
どんな料理にもできるし
何の甘さもないんです
料理したらすごい美味しく食べられる
熟しちゃったらものすごい激甘い
もう糖尿病になるかもしれません
食べちゃったらそれぐらい甘いんです
ですから熟したら果物で
そこそこまでは野菜で
マンゴーも同じなんです
マンゴーは熟する前にものすごい酸っぱいですね
酸っぱくて食べられないほど
それでもそれはいろいろ料理に使うんですね
酸っぱい味の料理として
まあよくだったらリンゴもいろいろ野菜として使うんだけどね
サワーリンゴありますね
酸っぱいリンゴ それは野菜ですとか漬物とか
まあそれはどうでもいいんですけど
まあ一応定義できると
定義できるんだからといって
何か本物をこれというものはない
それだけなんですね 僕は言いたがっているのは
じゃあ心っていうのは定義できる
心の定義っていうのは認識という働き
いわゆる知るという働き
心が 知るはこういう風なもんですか？違う
で 知るということですね
あの認識の識と書いて知ると書いたっても
大体おなじみなんです
その漢字 漢字としては
この漢字もこの漢字よりそちらの漢字の方がいいかもしれません
言偏ですね 言偏 知る 識の
ですから漢字としては 2つ書けられますけど
とにかく知るという機能は心でありますと
それは心の定義 でもだからって知る人
知るものが知る人がいるわけではないんです
誰がこの体の中でこの知る機能をやってますかと探せば見つからない
でも知るという機能はあるんです
目で知る 耳で知る 鼻で知る
体で知る いわゆる知る
感じる どっちでもいいんです
何もしないで 頭の中でいろんなことを回転
概念を回転させながらいろんなことを知る
寝ていても知る 知るということはいつでもあるんです
外は暑いか寒いか知っている
そういう風に環境を知る
内と外を知ることは心なんですね
内と外というのは こちらに私がいて
外の世界を知る それだけではなくて
この物体そのもののことも知る
もし私に私の体があるということを知らなかったならば
もう何もできませんだから
人に潰されても知りませんだから
ですから 内と外 いわゆる外の世界と内の世界
両方知る その悲しみ苦しみっていうのは内なる知ることなんですね
あれは綺麗ですよとか思うと
外のことを知ることなんですね
ですからまあ 外界 内外という両方知ること
心なんです そう言うと
ただ知ることだから そこら辺には別に大差さがないんです
知ることによって知るものは違うからかもしれませんだけど
知るということはただ同じこと
ミミズが自分に目がないんだだから皮膚で知る
我々には目があるんだから
目で外の世界知る ですから
ミミズの心と私の心は違いますよというのはおかしいんです
ミミズにも目一つつけてあげれば目でも知るんです
で 人間にも鼻があって
犬にも鼻がある でも人間の鼻に掴めるのはほんのちょっとの香りだけなんですね
ほんのかすか それでも三回嗅いだらわからなくなっちゃうんです
どんないい香りであろうか
一回嗅いだら香りがいいと
二回嗅ぐとそういい香りですね
三回嗅ぐとわからないんですね
それくらい弱いんですね
この嗅覚というのは じゃあ犬はどうですかね
迷子になっても十キロ
二十キロで百キロでもちゃんと歩いてくるんです
自分のお家に あれ 匂いで来るんです
それぐらいものすごい領域を幅広く知ってるんです
で それだったら犬の方が偉いでしょうに
人間よりは それで視覚といえば
この鳥なんか もう一キロ二キロ先の
だからこの空飛ぶ鷲とかその系統の鳥
鳥なんかはもうすごい高いところを飛んでるんだけど
草の上に走ってるネズミをちゃんとあれネズミだと知ってるんだから
人間にはもう絶対見えない
その鳥の目に目と同じ視力のこの
あれ この望遠鏡みたいなものを作ることさえ難しいんです
なぜかっていうと 望遠鏡だったら遠いものを見れるんだけど
近いもの見えないんです
でも鳥にはそば これも見えて
もう二メートル二キロ先のことも見える
見えるだけじゃなくて
鮮明に明確に見える ですから
視覚はもうすごいんですね
私たちにはそんな世界見えません
で この紫外線のこの紫色ですか
それも見えるんですね
鳥と蝶々なんかには だから私たちは黄色い花だなという花には
またいろんな色があるんです
いろんな模様がついているんです
でも人間にその模様は見えない
蝶々にそれに見える そういうことだから
蝶々の方が人間よりは偉いと
ワシの方が人間に偉いとかね
犬の方が人間よりはと言えないし
ミミズのミミズよりは人間の方が偉いとも言えないんです
もうただどれぐらい知るかということだけで
いわゆる知る領域 範囲ですね
知る範囲はその生命によって様々なんですね
大体知る範囲はすごい狭いのは人間なんですね
この原理 接近の範囲はすごく狭い
人間 だから人間も本当は狭い世界に生きてるんです
そんなに巨大な世界 巨大な世界を認識してるわけじゃないんです
人間と他の動物違うところはもう妄想概念だけなんですね
知ったものについて もう延々と回転させちゃう
体の中では 回転させて回転させて
膨大な知る絵の具作る
動物の場合は膨大な量をいきなり知る
考える必要ないんです
だから我々は妄想ということで補っているんです
動物に付いている能力を
まあそこまあこれはもう別にまああまり真剣に考えなくてもいいんだけど
一応アビダルマでは言いたいところは
知るという機能にとしては差がない
差別はないんだと 知るという機能は誰にでも同じことである
ですから 心はどれぐらいありますかというと
一つですよと言うんです
この一つですよというのは
なんかすごくなんか解らぬと言葉なんです
それは知るという機能は一つしかないんだからだけなんです
心はいっぱいたくさんあるというならば
知るものによって差をつけるしかないんです
目で知る 耳で知ると ですから
目で知る心と耳で知る心といえば二つになりますけど
知るということにすれば一つですね
で ですから心はたくさんありますよと言いたければ
まあそうと 心は一つですよと言いたければ
まあそれも結構ですよと
水がありますよと言うたら
もう一つですね 水っていうのは一つなんですね
一つで物足らないんだと思ったら
いくらでも水の種類があるんです
山の水 川の水 湧き水 井戸水とかね
水道の水とか 海の水とか
いくらでもあるんです
それで海の水といったっても
そのその場所の水の内容がまた違うんですね
ですから さあ必要だよというならば
もう頑張ってください
いくらでもあります それはややこしいというならば
水一つしかない ですから
私はこの心と精神の差を説明する場合は
大体水の例なのよ よく出すのは
水が一つしかない でも水道の水と井戸の水は違う
なぜ違いますかというと
水道の水の中に溶けているものと
湧き水 井戸の水の中に溶けているものは違いますから
で 紅茶あります お茶ありますよというと全く別なもの
でも水は同じなんです
水は同じですけど 中に入っているものは違う
ですから 紅茶はちゃんとありまして
お茶もちゃんとあるんです
水としてみると 水としてみると同じこと
差はない ですから心は一つしかない
それからこのまあ個人個人の心は別々なんですね
例えば我々みんなにあるのは一つの心ですよと言っちゃったら
みんな同じ一つになっちゃうんですね
そうはならないんですね
十人いると心は十あります
なぜならば 私が知るものは他の人は知らないんだから
ですから ある全ての生命に心という働きはあるんです
それで心は別々なんです
そうすると この存在の中でどれぐらい心がありますか？って
それももうちょっとわからない
言いにくい 素性の数は無限であって
もう考えられないほどなんですね
で 人の心 例えばミミズの心
心が自分に乗り移るということはないんです
ミミズの心はあくまでミミズの心です
影響は入りますけど あの
いわゆる共鳴という働きで共鳴